[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSH SHAPIRO: So we are the
Los Angeles Community Broadband
Project.
I'm Josh Shapiro, the founder
and acting executive director.
We're building a
community-driven wireless
ISP in Los Angeles.
That's an Internet
Service Provider
that is built by the
community for the community.
And we've started
by assembling a team
of community members,
professionals
in each of their areas.
And our goal is to create an
ISP that has and maintains
a symbiotic relationship
between the customer or a member
and the business, which is very
different than the model we're
all currently familiar with.
So moving along, we believe that
the root of the problem right
here in Los Angeles
and elsewhere
is a lack of competition.
The incumbent ISPs,
they operate off
of anti-competitive
model, where their goal is
to segregate a
portion of the market
and sort of territorialize
it to maintain control.
That has obvious problems for
the consumer, being that--
all of the symptoms of an
anti-competitive market.
It's expensive.
The customer service is poor.
The service quality
itself is lower.
And now we're
running into problems
where we're starting
to see what we believe
are the beginnings of the
monetization of the internet
like cable television.
The big step in that
direction is, of course,
the FCC decision to repeal
Title II and net neutrality.
That is just a precursor on
a potential multi-step path
to building internet services
into a tiered system, where
there's a fast-track lane
and a slow-track lane.
And if you're not paying or
if the services aren't paying,
then your access to that
content at the consumer level
could be limited,
possibly restricted.
At the very least,
it's an inconvenience.
At the most, you could be
talking about the difficulties
to access specific information,
which has its implications.
So most of you, though,
at a consumer level
right now, are sort
of feeling the strain
and the inconvenience level.
And just sort of break
down one of the symptoms
of a territorialized
market, I guess,
is the service quality
itself and the cost of it.
So we just took one
customer's service plan
on an incumbent ISP--
it's a 100 megabit plan--
and started to just run
some numbers off of that.
It's $65 a month for
on a non-promo rate.
I think it drops to
about $50 on a promo.
But then, of course,
there's no incentive
to keep people on
promotional rates.
You might have the opportunity
to bounce from promo to promo.
But in a lot of areas that
are not duopolies, but are
monopolies, you might
just be told, no, you
don't have any other option.
And they know you don't
have any other option.
We started to test average
speeds over a period of time.
And at least in this case, the
100 megabit plan, only half
the time, was greater than
50 megabit per second.
So you're looking at an
average of about 70.6 megabit
per second download and 7.9
megabit per second upload.
So while you're
sometimes hitting
the numbers, a good deal
of the time, you're not.
And that mainly comes down
to over-subscription ratio.
There are other factors.
But oversubscribing
your customer base
is one of the easiest
ways to, I guess,
pull in more revenue to sort
of stretch your network further
and further.
So for example, say
you have 1 megabit
per second on your network to
divvy out to your customers.
So a typical ISP, you might
be looking at multiplying
that something like 100 to 1.
So you're selling 100 megabit
worth of service off of your 1
megabit.
The idea there is that
not all of your customers
will be using that
service or maxing out
that service at one time.
So you can kind of play
around with over subscription.
That's a necessary component
of the business model.
But when you start to
oversubscribe more, and more,
and more, then you start
to get into this pattern
where, if you were testing,
it's an unhealthy network,
where, during peak times or when
multiple users are overlapping
and using their service, the
total capacity is being divided
down, and down, and down
until you're dipping
into the 25s, the 10s, the 5s.
You're getting a small
fraction of your service.
Now it might only be for
a short period of time.
But some are like
Los Angeles, where
you could be sharing with
hundreds or thousands of people
off of nearby hubs.
You could be talking about
experiencing these dips
every single day during peak
hours, which is typically,
like, 4:00 to
7:00, 4:00 to 8:00,
people are coming home
and using their internet.
And so if that's your main
internet browsing time
or internet
experience, on a whole,
you will be paying for
your, say, 100 plan,
but then usually only
getting a fraction of that.
So another issue that
we see is there's
a growing digital divide between
low-income and high-income
users.
The problem there is
that newer technologies
are being invested in areas
that are higher income, where,
as far as a business
standpoint, there's
an earlier return on
investment, because there
are more users in that area that
we'll use that new technology.
So in a sense, maybe
the lower-income users
won't utilize as
much fiber, simply
because they can't afford it.
But then the problem is is
that there's no option there.
So actually looking at
the breakdowns here--
I know this font
is a little small,
so I'll walk you through it.
There was a report released last
year by the Berkeley Housing
Institute that showed that
34% of Los Angeles households,
approximately 730,000 homes in
Los Angeles on AT&T's network,
did not have access to
high-speed broadband
as defined by the FCC as 25
megabit per second or greater.
So you've got 730,000 people
just on AT&T's network alone
in Los Angeles that
don't have broadband.
That's incredible.
Somewhere like Los Angeles with
12-something million people,
you've got neighborhoods,
and some of them are--
we're looking at District 10.
We're looking at Culver City.
It's not just low
income, but this problem,
it really affects everyone.
There are entire
neighborhoods that they
will offer cable service or
higher service up to a street.
And then you'll have a
neighborhood of maybe 30,000
people that are stuck on DSL.
So one of our missions is
to grow the accessibility
and service area by providing
high-speed broadband to areas
that are still on DSL and then
also make it more affordable.
Moving along, so our
mission in a nutshell
is to offer better
quality service.
So that's more
consistent speeds,
especially during peak
times, mainly through lower
over-subscription rates.
We're looking at something like
a 10 to 1, as opposed to 101--
fair pricing, more affordable.
We can't last in, say, a
price war against a major ISP.
But our goal is to charge
a fair market rate--
which right now,
looks like something
about $10 less than what you
typically get out there--
and to improve
accessibility to broadband,
so to serve those communities
that are currently under-served
and provide higher speeds to
the areas that don't currently
have it.
Net neutral, no filters, no
throttling, none of that--
and then we want
cellular browsing data.
That's something that, while
being more accessible and more
affordable, those are
separate components.
We think the net neutrality and
knots touching your data sort
of goes hand-in-hand with
our moral commitments
to the community.
So taking a look
at the hardware,
the tech out there is
probably the coolest part
of this that allows us
to make this possible.
We're working with a new
kind of prosumer technology--
it's only been out in the
market for a few years--
that's developed into a
new style of architecture.
It's got a couple names.
But the big one is
MicroPop architecture.
That's where we're-- instead
of providing wide-area coverage
to a large area
using a sector tower,
we're back hauling or we're
using a point-to-point link
from a tower down to a hub,
I guess this access point
station, usually on someone's
roof, or a telephone pole,
something along those lines.
And that provides area coverage
to the house around it.
So real quickly,
this is a MicroPop--
Rob will be talking
about these in a minute--
MicroPop and a
client-side antenna.
This is what the client side
would typically look like,
something like a small
bowl style antenna.
There are various
shapes and sizes, but--
AUDIENCE: The one on the right.
JOSH SHAPIRO: The one on
the right-- yes, sorry.
One of our goals
is to also build
a system that's
non-intrusive, since that's
one of the concerns
for municipalities
is they're thinking
back to the dish
days of having giant satellite
dishes on people's roofs.
And there are some
walls around that.
So making it small
and non-intrusive
is another aspect of that.
Walking through a network,
so our current goal and focus
right now is on Culver City.
For a test pilot, it's got
a topographical advantage
with a giant hill
next to a dense--
I would say, like
a suburban area--
with a tall tower.
We're talking with the city
about utilizing that tower
for our test pilot and beyond.
So walking through sort of
the MicroPop model here,
we have our tower backhauling
down to an access point
on the ground, which, itself,
can have several clients.
That access points
deliver service around it
and can also bridge to
nearby access points.
So part of the
goal of this system
is to limit the number
of tower locations
you need to build in redundancy
and sort of lower cost.
The more tower space you need,
the higher the lease price is.
So most of our network design
is designed around affordability
and reliability-- so making it
as affordable and accessible
as possible without sacrificing
much in the reliability area.
That translates to something
more like this, as far
as an actual network design.
It might be hard to see on here,
but just to walk through it.
So this is a view
of Culver City.
On the south of this image is
the Culver City downtown area
where Washington and
Culver kind of collide.
And on the right side
is around Sony Studios.
So we have this
overlook tower, which
we've learned will be
supplied with fiber itself.
So we don't have to do
any kind of relaying.
From here, we can backhaul
down to access points
in the neighborhoods,
which each have about--
those MicroPops are about
1,000-foot radius or so.
They're line of sight.
So we've sort of gone
through and roughly
mapped out that each one could
hit around 50 structures or so
wherever they're located.
So they'll be a little
overlap, in order
to hit all of those homes.
And then in green are
links from one access
point that has backhaul from the
tower to another access point.
So you can start to build
out your network access
point to access point.
It has this granularity
to it that you might not
had if you were
installing wireline.
And the return investment
on these things,
if you have enough
clients on them,
could be something like
six to nine months.
So they pay themselves
off really quickly.
And you can just kind
of toss them wherever
you need to expand your area.
Let's see, the
benefits to society--
there's the tech side of
things, and there's also
the community aspect.
The biggest one is
creating competition.
Right now, any
kind of competition
would start to alleviate
some of the issues we
see in the price,
the service quality.
And now, even though it could
be difficult on our side coming
into a market and
even if we can compete
at a cost perspective
for some time,
it does force the
competition down
to either compete or
to play with PR hit.
So we're hoping we can help
other people out on that.
Educating the consumer
is a big deal.
Things like cord cutting can
help people save hundreds
per month, instead of just $10.
We've been reaching
out to our community
through nextdoor.com
and a few others.
And we have a ton of neighbors
in the Culver City area
that are paying over
$100 for bundled packages
that they don't
really use, or seniors
that don't understand Netflix
and streaming, and YouTube TV,
and those kind of things.
Educating them on those--
that they exist-- and
helping them migrate over
could help them save
a ton per month.
There's a open-source
development aspect of this.
A lot of software on our
back end uses open source.
So would we would be
helping those open source
communities by
developing modules
and the aspects that we need.
Ultimately, our goal is to
package this in an open wiki
so other communities
and other citizens
can build this for themselves
in their own community
or maybe even build
something else somewhere
else in Los Angeles.
Since LA is a beast to tackle,
we definitely need the help.
And we think the best
way to do that is
to put it all out there,
make it very turnkey,
and then support other people
in building themselves.
We're looking into low-income
and student support programs,
where there's some things
that are experimental that
are in the works.
We still have to do
some stuff on it,
but looking at ideas
like bandwidth sharing,
or bandwith donations
built into the service,
optional donating an extra
small amount per month
to buy plans for low income,
and then working with the cities
to, I guess,
officialize low income,
and find out who those people
are, and qualify, and all that.
And then lastly,
something that's
sort of new but
we're working on it
is a neighborhood health
program and building
in sort of a social
element to all of this.
Nextdoor.com does it
in an interesting way.
And that's a model we
might want to explore.
But they create
neighborhood leads
for every pocket of each
neighborhood, I guess.
It's usually a few
streets, or a block,
or some kind of
section like that.
But they have people sort of
assign themselves a leader
for their neighborhood.
And then that person can
help nearby neighbors.
And that might be an
interesting model for servicing.
There's some things we've
got to work out there,
like how much they
can do, insurance,
and that kind of stuff.
But initially, our idea
is, someone like that,
we could lightly train.
They could come in.
We could lightly
train them to do, say,
educating the consumer aspects
where they're hooking people
up with Netflix and helping
them walk through it.
And then, on our behalf,
they could help people
that we assign in
trade for, say, like,
a credit toward the internet.
So involving more of the
community to, at least,
do the light stuff that helps
us in the long run support
our network could
really help things move.
So we've got a
test pilot that's--
I'll talk about
timelines in a second.
But we're working on designing
a test pilot right now
for Culver City, something on
the order of 30 to 50 clients
to start with.
It might grow from there.
And right now, we're
looking into building
in criterias for success.
So what would be a
successful pilot?
Well, it needs to be reliable,
sustainable, scalable--
so testing multiple access point
scaling and that kind of stuff.
The proof of design, looking at
how this new sort of wireless
prosumer-grade
technologies operate--
we're sort of exploring
how much we have to spend
for what quality of equipments.
And the sky's the limit.
But the real
affordability comes down
in the entry-level
equipment, where you get
a lot of bang for your buck.
But somewhere like Los Angeles,
from an RF perspective,
is very challenging, so looking
into, what modules work best?
What equipment works best?
And then ultimately,
customer feedback--
we would need to hear from our
customers in the test pilot
to sort of tweak that model.
We want to play with things like
over-subscription, other ideas.
Like say you're paying
for a 25 megabit plan,
but it's not peak hours.
It might be possible to
just open that throttle up
for those users.
And maybe there's no reason to
force them down into 25 megabit
all the time if there's extra
headroom on the network.
Looking at more of a
business side of things,
we're planning out
just different phases
of expansion starting
with a local level,
with the goal being about
500 customers in Culver City.
There are some basic outlines
for revenue and expenses.
But the real challenge
is just getting started.
Like any startup, there are
expenses that we have to cover,
especially employee costs, for
all aspects of the business,
and outreach,
marketing sales, tech.
And by our phase 2, we
can push through that,
and we have our sort of minimal
needs met for employees.
And then as you scale up,
the biggest cost of this
would be employee
costs for service,
and maintenance, installation,
and the equipment itself,
which is about something like a
quarter of the employee costs.
So again, our big focus is
reducing those employee costs
by bringing in experienced
community members
to help support us.
And then our progress
so far-- so we've
assembled a team of
professionals right here.
We've designed an RF
and technology model
that we're continuing to
address as new tech comes out
on the market.
It's almost
month-the-month right now.
Some of the tech we're
waiting for could be huge.
And it's landing any day.
But there's some on the horizon.
So it's extremely fast-paced,
these wireless solutions,
the way they're growing.
We're meeting with
LA-area municipalities.
So right now, we're in
talks with Culver City
to deploy their first.
We've reached out
to West Hollywood
and met with their
technology team.
They're interested,
even though they're
a very small municipality.
They're looking at deploying
mini fiber in the next six
months.
So it could be ripe.
And then we've
talked to LA itself
and reached out to
city officials--
right now, District 10,
I believe District 3.
And we're starting
to explore what this
might look like in Los Angeles.
Now LA is a much bigger
beast to tackle politically
than in Culver City
or West Hollywood,
so we'd probably
be getting our foot
in the door in
smaller municipalities
and then expanding
into LA when we can.
There are permits
and other hurdles
to cross that might
take more time for LA
than for the smaller
municipalities.
So it's just one step at a time.
And then lastly, we're
looking for investors.
So there are a couple
of different ways
you could do this.
Other community ISPs,
they've started small
and seeded using investment from
even neighbors-- so collecting
a couple thousand here,
a couple of thousand
there on a low-interest loan
or a zero-interest loan,
and then growing organically,
and paying it off.
We're actually in contact
with a small community
WISP, Wireless
ISP, out in Golden,
Colorado called Au Wireless.
And they started with, I
believe, it was around $8,000.
So it can start very
small and grow from there.
We're looking at a
little more than that,
because we're tackling
a bigger beast.
But at least from an
investor standpoint,
it's very approachable
for communities.
It could be just a
series of houses.
It could be an HOA could get
together and do something
like this.
Really, the biggest
challenge there
is how you're getting
your service for your ISP.
And in our case, the answer is
through Culver City's Culver
Connect Community Wi-Fi
that's being finished
in the next couple months here.
They're able to transport
us down to 1 Wilshire
to access very
affordable level 2.
To our timeline, we've
got a tech demo coming up
in the next month that we
hope to show to some people,
especially the municipalities
that are interested,
to sort of fast track
some of the permitting
and that kind of stuff.
For the tech demo,
we hope to set up
a handful of these in a park.
And they will emulate the
access point on the client side.
And we want to start
to look at speeds.
How many clients
can we get on these?
What kind of air interference
we may be looking at.
Can it punch
through foliage well
if it's in an access point?
So that's coming up.
We've got our test pilot
for our first deployments
sometime in September.
That might depend on Culver
City and what their time
line is for their fiber.
But currently, that
looks like it's on track.
And then moving forward beyond
that would be early next year
hitting our first phase 1,
sort of the first official
deployment where we're
expanding into the neighborhood,
and we have a more long-term
models for scalability,
and then scaling beyond that.
Hopefully, sometime
next year, we'd
be able to get
permitting from LA.
The Bureau of Engineering
deals with all that and zoning.
So that's one hurdle.
But those are the big ones.
And then it'd be
expanding from there.
Let's see.
And that's it.
So we'll wrap that.
I'm going to bring
up all my guys.
And we're going to
start kind of a Q&A
to kind of get some
back and forth going on.
So hop on up.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOSH SHAPIRO: OK.
Who's got a question?
You got a-- yeah!
AUDIENCE: So I have
a question, which
is, shut up and take my money.
Well, I guess it's not
technically a question.
So let me ask you two
other things quickly.
One is, in all
seriousness, how quickly
do you think you
can get to Pasadena?
JOSH SHAPIRO: Oh, man.
Actually, I've got
an interesting answer
in the Pasadena, specifically.
So Pasadena, there's
a big cogent data
center out in Pasadena.
And there's some great
hill access antennas.
Pasadena was actually
one of our first areas
that we were looking at
because of that data center
being really easy
access to level 2.
So I would say that
it would be more of a,
how difficult would Pasadena
be for our west-side-based team
to service?
But if we could get
past that hurdle,
maybe the answer would
be, if we started
to build our own
network in Culver,
but someone was interested
in starting something
like that in Pasadena, we
could sort of seed them
with all of our turnkey and
be very hands-on with them
to get that started,
especially since we've
done some preliminary
research over there.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thank you.
My other question--
I had a little more
of a technical question.
I noticed that your
backhaul, I guess it is,
is by millimeter wave.
So I know this is not
a huge problem in LA.
But do you have
measures of, like,
how badly that degrades in rain?
JOSH SHAPIRO: So talking
about the millimeter
wave and the wavelengths, so
we're looking at, for backhaul,
just to start with-- because
it's super affordable-- we'd
be either doing 24 gigahertz
or 5 gigahertz unlicensed.
Unlicensed Isn't
great for backhaul.
But 24 is pretty affordable.
It's like $3,000 a link,
something around there.
And the rain degradation
is negligible.
Even for the 60 gig, it's not
bad if you're not going far.
And it rains so
rarely in Los Angeles.
And most of the radios have
a 5 gigahertz fail back.
So if it starts raining, they
can switch over, no big deal.
AUDIENCE: Cool, thanks.
JOSH SHAPIRO: Cool, thank you.
AUDIENCE: What does all
these links do to the ping?
You talked a lot
about the speed.
What about the pings?
JOSH SHAPIRO: Oh,
great question.
Do any of you want
to talk about--
all right, I'll take
this one real quick.
I do have the
figures in my head.
So you're asking what
rain does to the latency?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
or how is latency?
JOSH SHAPIRO: Or how does
the latency look like?
Oh, great.
Well, in a nutshell,
radio moves faster
through the air than
light through optics.
So we're looking
at something like--
depends on how many hops
or how many access points.
But you could be looking at
sub-1 millisecond numbers,
upwards to somewhere around 8.
Right now, most of the stuff
we're looking at is 1 to 2.
So it's been very good.
I think most of our coax speed
tests are like in the 20s.
So I think we can beat that.
AUDIENCE: I guess this is
a pretty obvious question.
But given how most areas
in LA are or in Americas
are monopolies and duopolies.
Why hasn't this
been done before?
JOSH SHAPIRO: Great question--
looking at you guys,
hoping that will--
all right.
MARLEY JAFFE: I mean,
just to start off,
this concept of a wireless
ISP has been done before.
So we're not revolutionary
in that world.
I think where we're
revolutionary is that we're
trying to do it here in LA.
So that's just sort
of the baseline
is that other communities
and other areas,
both rural and
not-so-rural-- maybe
not necessarily as densely-based
as we are here in LA--
but do have solutions like this.
We are trying to
stand out in being
net neutral, and
community-focused, and driven,
and things like that.
But the technology behind
this concept is nothing new.
Although, there are new
developments that are helping
us succeed faster, and better,
more efficiently in LA.
JOSH SHAPIRO: To add to
that, I would say that--
on, at least, the tech front--
handling Los Angeles
kind of density
was previously an issue.
So I think that
technology to address
high-density areas, metro,
urban has more recently
become more affordable.
CRAIG DUFFY: And
related to that is also
the help to lower-income
community members
that we're going
to be trying to do.
That's another factor
that hasn't really
been done by others.
So that's one of the
other things that's trying
to set us above everybody else.
JOSH SHAPIRO: Great.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOSH SHAPIRO: All right.
AUDIENCE: Why did you
decide to go to nonprofit?
Wouldn't it be easier to raise
money if you were for-profit?
JOSH SHAPIRO: We're
actually non a nonprofit.
I'll have Gabriel touch on that.
Well let him explain that.
GABRIEL OLSON: So
the plan is actually
to look at incorporating
as a benefit corporation
so that we can have,
basically, a dual bottom line,
both be profitable, but
also have a social mission
to provide social benefit,
and legally ensconce
that in the kind of
bylaws of our company
so that we are able to take
advantage of investment,
and sort of scale
up in the future,
and add lots of infrastructure,
and expensive investments all
of that sort, but also
maintain a responsibility
to the community.
[INAUDIBLE]
ROMAN TATARNIKOV: Also,
just to add to it, actually
it's legally required
for benefit corporations
to show that they're doing
their social mission and so on.
So even if we're going
to be a corporation,
we still have this
social effect.
And we're actually legally
responsible for it.
JOSH SHAPIRO: OK, great.
Anyone else?
AUDIENCE: How geography-bound
are you, meaning most of LA
is surrounded by hills
to some distance.
But how far away
from the hill can you
be before you start having
to build really tall towers?
JOSH SHAPIRO: I missed the
very beginning of the question.
AUDIENCE: Basically,
how far from a hill
do you have to be
before you have to start
building really tall towers?
JOSH SHAPIRO: Great question.
So the technologies
we're using can
go across Los Angeles Valley.
There's no range
limitation there.
The real issue is line of sight.
So being high off
the ground, and being
able to point down
on people's roofs,
instead of hitting
across a ton of foliage,
or structures,
that kind of stuff,
it will really be a
case-to-case basis.
Some areas are
easier than others.
We don't necessarily need to
utilize a bunch of towers.
There are people on the edge
of hillsides, like for example,
West Hollywood.
There might be a
house that will be
able to host an access point.
And we can just point
it right down from there
and use it as a relay, as well.
We would want to look
into towers in cases--
or at least, buildings using
antenna locations in cases
where we can't serve
that area without them.
But it should be rare.
CRAIG DUFFY: Related to that
is there are some areas where
you've got a valley that has
10, 20, 30 houses in it that
don't really have
anything faster than DSL.
And so we have the
advantage of, we
don't have to lay wire
down for those people.
All we do is get up.
We send a transmit to one of
the houses on top of that hill
or on the edge of a valley.
And then if that can
hit everybody else,
then we've got that whole
neighborhood covered.
MATTHEW VITALE: Me
and the tech team,
we touched on this
a little bit more.
We did a torture test from
Culver to West Hollywood,
I believe, where
it was about 5.8--
JOSH SHAPIRO: 5.7 miles.
This was on
entry-level equipment.
But it was doable.
I think that, touching back
on Craig's response, one
of the big advantages
of this platform,
as opposed to a traditional
sector tower layout,
is that we can use
private rooftops.
So in somewhere
like Los Angeles,
you're not building any
more towers anywhere.
Actually that was, I
think, a quote from one
of the council member staff.
So we have to find another way.
And one of the ways to do that
is to use people's rooftops.
So I guess with
fewer doors opening,
enough to provide the zoning,
and that kind of stuff
that would allow us to
attach some of the smaller
equipment on people's homes,
we can use them as our towers.
And instead of having to
cast down upon a huge area,
we can kind of do a zigzag
approach, where we're literally
expanding pockets at a time,
40 houses at a time, 50
houses at the time, zigzagging
our way line of sight
through these neighborhoods.
Now down the road,
you might a tree
grow in the way of
some line or someone
might build a structure
in front of that.
It's OK.
You can just reroute.
The WISPs we've been
talking to that deal
with suburban
environments, they've
become accustomed to needing
to kind of organically
grow around things.
And when obstacles pop
up, you sort of just
make your way around
them in other ways.
It sort of works out.
ROMAN TATARNIKOV: And to add
to it, about the actual tower
set, and the antenna service,
and the customers, that's
pretty much their last mile.
But if we're talking
about connecting
different neighborhoods
far away from each other,
it can very easily done.
Because I have personally have
been on top of 1 Wilshire.
And I saw how there was
a wireless backhauling
for 1 Wilshire to 100 Wilshire,
which is in Santa Monica.
So we're talking from
downtown LA to Santa Monica.
So for those direct links,
it's something very possible.
JOSH SHAPIRO: Great.
One more question?
AUDIENCE: I have
one more question.
I hope that's all right.
What are your plans for
large apartment buildings?
And when I say
apartment buildings,
I'm more thinking about
lower-income areas,
so not the nice areas
here along the beach where
they actually updated
their call boxes
so they work with cell phones.
I'm talking about the ones
that would never do that,
and maybe you are going to
let you put little antennas,
or it's not feasible to
put the little antennas
outside every unit.
JOSH SHAPIRO: Right.
So we're actually building
a technology model
that works around all of
the sort of data equipment
or hellish boxes we
might come across
in some of these older complex.
And you'd be
surprised, it doesn't
need to be a low-income
structure for it not
to be touched for 50
years or whatever.
So one of our tech models--
actually, maybe Marley
can speak to this theory.
We're looking at
battery backup systems
and using exterior ethernets
and that kind of stuff to equip.
Do you want to talk a little
bit about kind of our UPS?
MARLEY JAFFE: Yeah, I can.
But we also want to touch on
why we can put these antennas
on people's roofs.
JOSH SHAPIRO: Oh,
yeah, go for it.
MARLEY JAFFE: Well, I'll
let you touch on that part.
So our sort of model for
medium-sized apartment
buildings--
bigger than one to two,
duplex, fourplex units,
but smaller than 50
apartment buildings--
is, essentially, reverse
power over ethernet.
So each apartment
that has the service
has a router, just like
everyone has in their apartment.
But that's actually
providing power back up
to the equipment that's
on someone's roof
or on the apartment
complex's roof.
And as long as one person
is providing that power,
the entire system stays up.
So if multiple apartments lose
power for whatever reason,
as long as one
person still has it,
then all of the equipment
on the roof stays powered.
And then everyone
inside the apartment
should keep internet, as well.
For buildings that are going
to be the access point--
so serving other
buildings in the area--
those will also have
battery backups.
And all of this
equipment will be
able to be monitored by us
to ensure that, when a power
outage goes out, we're aware.
If it starts getting
close to the time
that the battery
will be depleted,
we'll have backup
solutions in place,
or we'll be repairing
backup solutions
so that large areas
of the community
don't lose internet,
and just maybe
that one building or
something like that.
JOSH SHAPIRO: And
touching on the what
if landlords don't allow
it, as long as long
as we're permitted at the
city level, it's allowed.
There's actually a specific
language written by the FCC
that doesn't allow
landlords to prevent you
from attaching an antenna to
your roof for internet access.
So the real challenge would
just be getting past the city.
If that's clear,
then we won't have
to deal with the landlords.
CRAIG DUFFY: One
thing related to that
is the access points use very
low amounts of electricity.
It's like a light bulb or two.
JOSH SHAPIRO: Yeah,
it's something
along the order of 50 watts--
could be give or take 20 watts.
But you're looking at
$50 a year, $60 a year.
So the goal with the
access point model,
the MicroPop model,
from that standpoint,
is we're mainly targeting
private households,
because the exchange
is a little simpler.
But the traditional model is
that you offer free service
to anyone that's hosting it--
so free top-tier service.
So instead of them paying
$80 a month, or $60 a month,
or whatever it is, they're
getting free service.
And it's really just
at the cost of powering
the access point itself.
ROMAN TATARNIKOV: And
just to make sure,
we will mention that if
the building loses power.
Even if the building
loses power,
we still have the batteries.
So don't freak out.
JOSH SHAPIRO: Great.
AUDIENCE: So forgive my
ignorance on this point.
But why can't you-- or can you?
But is there some legal
restriction or something
that keeps you from putting
your equipment on existing cell
towers?
JOSH SHAPIRO: There's
nothing that prevents us
from putting our equipment
on existing cell towers,
it's just the cost of doing so.
AUDIENCE: Really?
JOSH SHAPIRO: It's usually
cost-prohibitive, especially
for something like us.
That would be a major
expense across the network.
And we'd have to raise prices
to compensate for that.
AUDIENCE: If somebody owns the
cell towers and charges you
money if you want to put your
equipment on the cell towers.
JOSH SHAPIRO: Right.
And it's usually--
AUDIENCE: That's how that works?
JOSH SHAPIRO: Exactly, yeah.
They charge you money for--
usually, it's,
like, square footage
or a certain amount of space.
There's no standards out there.
They could literally
look in your eye,
and think you're full of
money, and double the price
in front of you.
That's sort of what
we've been told
by people that are
working in the WISP market
here in Los Angeles.
AUDIENCE: OK, cool.
That make sense.
You also mentioned
something about there's
a restriction that
says, landlords
can't stop you from installing
an antenna on your roof
for internet access.
I live in an historic
neighborhood in Pasadena.
Do you know if the rules are
the same for those, as well?
JOSH SHAPIRO: That's
a great question.
I do not know.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I was just curious.
GABRIEL OLSON: Are there people
with DIRECTV on their roof
in your neighborhood?
AUDIENCE: Yes, there are,
the people, like, next to us.
But I think they're just out
of the historic neighborhoods.
So I'm not entirely sure.
But I think that they do.
And so I think
that I would be OK.
But I don't actually know this.
I just thought maybe you would.
JOSH SHAPIRO: Yeah,
we'll look into that.
That's actually the first
question of that kind.
AUDIENCE: Cool, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Have you guys seen
any push back from ISPs?
Or is there any intimidation?
And at the same rate,
is there anything
that the ISPs are doing,
in terms of innovation,
that you see as a
threat to your business?
JOSH SHAPIRO: That's
a great question.
Well, I'll touch
on the first point.
We haven't seen anything
yet, but we're very small.
That might change
as we grow and start
to pluck off a sliver of market
share somewhere on some chart.
But currently,
nothing in that area.
MARLEY JAFFE: I've seen
my internet get slower,
personally.
MATTHEW VITALE: Yeah, same here.
I've been getting
throttled a lot lately.
JOSH SHAPIRO: Yup.
ROMAN TATARNIKOV:
Yeah, let's wait
till this video gets uploaded.
And then we're done.
JOSH SHAPIRO: Yeah,
then we're done for.
Touching on the-- oh, I'm sorry.
I already forgot.
AUDIENCE: Innovation from ISPs.
JOSH SHAPIRO: Right, innovation.
Right now, I guess the
scope of technologies
look like they're moving more
and more toward wireless.
So there may be a point--
say, it's 10 years from now--
where most people, I guess,
last mile is all wireless.
Now I think there's already
something like-- what is it?
Like 50% of people access the
internet on mobile already--
or is that some figure
like that-- and growing.
So the real tackle
probably won't
be major ISPs, or at least
the coax technologies
aren't really concerned.
It's probably more
LTE tech that's--
we've got fifth gen
deployments coming out now.
And so competing with
mobile might be an issue
down the road.
But again, in that regard,
you're talking data caps.
They might not be net neutral.
Even if you aren't capped,
you're hitting some kind of 1%,
or threshold, or something like
that if you're a heavy user
and being throttled down.
So it might be some time,
maybe years and years from now,
where the technologies
in mobile or roaming
are cost-competitive with ours,
which is a fixed wireless.
But again, I think at
the end of the day,
our selling point will
be that where we're
different from everyone else.
Because we're built
by the community.
And we're for the community.
CRAIG DUFFY: I also
welcome the competition.
I mean, if someone else is
going to try and beat our prices
and do it better,
I think that's all
going to help everybody, right?
JOSH SHAPIRO: Right.
CRAIG DUFFY: So
that's ultimately
our goal is everybody gets
faster and cheaper internet.
Because it should be
utility that we all
get almost as a right.
So thinking bigger
picture there,
it's important to
all of us for that.
MARLEY JAFFE: Yeah,
it's not necessarily
the best business model.
But that's one of our
goals is to sort of have
some of the larger ISPs wake
up and realize that they've
been taking advantage,
and oversubscribing
to an unhealthy amount,
and things like that.
And if we can drive that
change here in Los Angeles
and in greater areas, that's
one of our mission accomplished.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for the talk.
So yeah, so on that,
I don't know if you
threw these numbers out there.
But you said that current ISPs
are oversubscribed by something
like 100 to 1.
And you are thinking of
doing it more like 10 to 1.
But still, more or less, it
seems like the same prices.
So I've never
thought about this.
Let me be very stupid.
But help me think about this.
Does that mean the ISP is
overcharging us by 10x?
Or do you have an
inefficiency of 10x?
Or how to think about this?
JOSH SHAPIRO: That's
a great question.
CRAIG DUFFY: On the nose.
JOSH SHAPIRO: There
are some efficiencies,
I think, in our
set-up over coax.
The biggest one is
probably the speed
of deployment, the super low
capital expenditure required,
those kind of things.
So it costs us less
for the equipment.
And we can deliver for less.
It's not as robust, per se, as
wireline or especially fiber.
Fiber, it's a huge initial cost.
And maybe you have a ROI
of, like, 10 or 20 years
in a neighborhood.
But it's always
going to be there.
And you can continue to
upgrade it in other ways.
The real issue with
fiber and wireline tech
is that, in somewhere
like Los Angeles,
I think the telecom
commissioner was
quoted as saying
that they'd hang him
if he dug up that many roads.
It creates traffic issues,
that kind of stuff.
And there's a cost
associated with that.
So a little bit of
tech advantage--
and then, on the
other side, we're
not seeing what their
books look like.
But a quick guess might
just be that they're
making a lot of money.
AUDIENCE: I'm not
that good at throwing.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, let's
just-- thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank
you guys so much.
Yeah, so this is also a bit
of an ignorant question.
But I know I've had friends
that have gotten letters
from their ISPs about
torrenting, RIAA, MPAA stuff.
And I was wondering,
to what degree you all
are responsible for
the types of traffic
that your customers use?
Even like child
pornography, are you
responsible for any of that?
Are there any legal
concerns that you have?
Do you have to build
up a lawyer team
to be able to respond to
these kinds of things?
Because I could imagine
the MPAA and RIAA
would be pretty formidable
opponents if they sued you.
JOSH SHAPIRO: Right.
I can answer to
probably the degree
of how other wireless ISPs
across the country do it.
But does anyone else
have specific answers
to any of that?
ROMAN TATARNIKOV:
Yeah, like [INAUDIBLE]..
Other ISPs, they
pretty much just ignore
all those complaints.
Mostly, they just forward
them onto the user.
Because realistically, it's a
job of ISPs to provide a pipe.
And it's the end user
who's responsible
for its own traffic.
Plus, ISPs, one of the
things we mentioned
is the way we're
different is we're also
respect user privacy.
So we're not selling data.
But we're also not trying
[INAUDIBLE] any content.
So if a certain user starts
torrenting or something,
then, yes, obviously, it
can be traced by IP address.
So we're pretty much
going to pass it to users.
There's nothing really
changed in this regard.
JOSH SHAPIRO: Use a VPN is the
end question for torrenting.
Use a VPN and throw
out those letters.
ROMAN TATARNIKOV:
Actually, there
was another thing
we were thinking
about is, since
we're a community,
to educate more in privacy,
that maybe we can partner
with some VPN providers,
and just partner up,
and provide a VPN
service with a discount.
So pretty much, we're
forward users to them.
And you get the discount.
JOSH SHAPIRO: And it
goes without saying
that we will be compliant
with all FCC laws as required.
ROMAN TATARNIKOV: Yeah.
And about the lawyers,
we're a business.
So we'll end up having
some kind of lawyers.
Plus, we will definitely
have auditors,
because we're benefit corp.
JOSH SHAPIRO: Right.
I would also want to touch
on, as far as torrenting
specifically, in doing
this as a community level,
there's a little bit
more of an aspect
of using your fair
share in the effort
to make it more
affordable for everyone.
So I think part of
that could be building
in a tier system on our side
for people that are heavy users.
And we're not talking data
caps or anything like that.
But people that use more,
the 99 percentile of users,
it does make it more
expensive on the ISP side.
So there might be some kind of
fairness program or something
like that.
Or could be as simple as saying,
hey, we know you're torrenting.
Can you do it less
during peak hours?
Or we'll have to quality
of service adjust you
or something like some.
ROMAN TATARNIKOV: Also,
it's important to remember
that torrenting does not
equal actual privacy violation
or anything like that.
Torrenting is just a method
of sharing the media.
So you can download Debian
or CentOS free torrents.
JOSH SHAPIRO: Great.
Anyone else?
AUDIENCE: Speaking
of competitors,
it looks like there's a lot of
satellite internet companies
that might be coming
online in the next--
you would know better than
me-- but some number of years.
JOSH SHAPIRO: Soon, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
How do you see them as either
partners or competitors?
JOSH SHAPIRO: I think,
right now, satellite's
currently more niche.
It stands to be
less and less so.
I think some big sat just
launched-- or will launch--
GABRIEL OLSON: Elon's
got one this week.
JOSH SHAPIRO: Oh, yeah,
if we want [INAUDIBLE]..
And their capabilities are
increasing quite a bit.
It will be soon
where satellite will
be able to compete, as
least speed-wise, maybe
not latency-wise with wireline.
So I think that's the technology
that will be on the horizon
that we'll just
have to look for.
But again, at the
very end of the day,
competition is healthier
for the consumer.
And that's the
heart of our project
is to benefit the end user.
So I think we'll
just kind of roll
with the punches on that one.
CRAIG DUFFY: Yeah,
satellite is slower.
But definitely, we want
more competition out there
to help move things along.
JOSH SHAPIRO: It won't be slow
for long, I guess is the point.
Do you have another question?
AUDIENCE: No, I was just kind
of fantasizing in my head,
like imagining one level of
your hierarchy being delivered
by satellite, so
then, perhaps, you
could replace the fiber that's
feeding your central tower.
JOSH SHAPIRO: That'd
be interesting.
I would guess that the
business model on the satellite
couldn't handle
backhaul for level 2.
It might be totally
cost-prohibitive.
But as far as competition,
it will definitely be there.
MARLEY JAFFE: Yeah, we're
very fortunate to be
in LA, geographically, as
well as with Culver City's
municipal fiber that they're
putting in being relatively
easy for us to get
to 1 Wilshire, which
is a very large internet
hub for the world.
And so, most likely, there
won't be a competing technology
that will give us better,
faster, more reliable, cheaper
backhaul internet.
But one day, who knows?
If Elon Musk gets his vision
or any of the other companies
out there, then maybe.
JOSH SHAPIRO: Yeah.
All righty, well, we're
running up on our 1:00 PM mark.
So we will wrap it there.
All right, thank you
so much for joining us.